j - cat avant le premier tour des
élections municipales de 2020 des
élections en danger en raison du
coronavirus ainsi un français sur quatre
envisage de ne pas se rendre aux urnes
ce dimanche les différents candidats
n'ont pas hésité à poursuivre leur
campagne pour michel larive députés elle
est fine la 2e circonscription de
l'ariège à la france insoumise a
sillonné tout le territoire avec des
listes citoyenne et beaucoup d'optimisme
écouter la france a soumises intègre
partout sur le territoire national des
listes de fédérations populaire
ce sont des risques citoyenne et donc
qu'elle participe à 550 lits sur tout le
territoire national
c'est plus que la république en marche
ça se passe plutôt bien
nous avons une capacité de mobilisation
des militants qui est très très très
intéressante
seulement dans des listes dites
citoyennes dans 90 % des 200 milles
habitants par exemple et donc notre
objectif c'est d'avoir le plus de
conseillers municipaux de mer et de
pouvoir havas mais notre politique notre
corpus politique qui est un corpus
humanis solidaires écologistes dans le
maximum de l'exécutif municipaux tout
sur tout le tour national et pour
jacques myard mer les républicains de
maisons laffitte les élus locaux sont
des hommes et des femmes d'allant avec
beaucoup d'expérience le profil type
pour remporter ces élections municipales
les français ont bien conscience
aujourd'hui que les maires notamment les
maires et l'air les maires delà des
républicains gère correctement leur
ville et sont des hommes d'expérience et
sont des hommes d'al ans donc c'est avec
une grande sérénité que je vais à la
rencontre de mes électeurs de mes
concitoyens en ce qui concerne bien sûr
mais sur la fuite mais je sais que c'est
quelque chose qui va se répéter dans de
très nombreuses villes
tant que le poteau des pas franchis tu
te ramasses en réalité qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'il faut pas
dormir sur ses deux oreilles
ce soir j'ai une réunion publique demain
soir j'ai une autre bulle ans
réunion publique et jeudi et vendredi
bien sûr je vais présent dans ma ville
et je sais c'est ce que font tous mes
collègues maires qui sont sortants vous
avez des gens qui sont ancrés dans le
territoire
ce sont les élus locaux de l air avec
d'autres d'ailleurs bien évidemment
parfois des sans étiquette mais surtout
dlr qui savent gérer leur ville qu'ils
sont véritablement établie qui ont le
sens du bien public et qui ont le sens
de la détermination dans la durée et la
cohérence
voilà ce qui se passe
[Musique]